[Music]
in urine addiction news
you're an addiction yeah like you're in
like Yuri Oh or you're an addiction like
they drink yes I was hoping for that one
Oh comrade detective sure you did
I did you mean the obsession towards a
gear my obsession oh that's the one
anyway I just noticed that you're
because JK news 2017 that's pretty funny
if you want to talk about how the
articles are so old I'm just you traded
from BuzzFeed to take us down that's
actually me commenting that wow these
articles are so old you guys suck oh you
are Steven Lim 3:55 are you my pin
number
dude everyone knows no one comes here
for the articles it's not the point
they come forward for that sweet ass
yeah but some people do and they come
with a fresh stick all the way up their
ass which is pretty fun submitted by JK
is goat somebody say BuzzFeed is going
well right now but ever heard go in
lowercase so it's the bad goat you're
maybe hot goatee bro gotcha they're
calling us goats nylon J cold milk is so
good
official hey baby
you guys ever see goat see no with that
what's good Oh goatee wait good goatee
is the it was it was this image that
went viral like when I was 13 or some
[ __ ] like a lemon party oh yeah it's
like a lemon party but it's like of a
grown man spreading his [ __ ] all the
way the [ __ ] out we're it to an insane
degree
by so was one of those things where it's
like it's like you open it and there's a
ah you got laid you ever got the
lemonparty one no oh so there was you
get an email and it's like you're
invited to the lemon party and then you
open the email and it's like a bunch of
guys [ __ ] each other well there are
no they're all sucking each other's
dicks not muscularly all like guys like
we all want you're right oh wrinkled
dude and they're like small kinda like
my small little small pump it was one
that was going around what was like oh I
want to sell my big black SUV click this
link and then check it out tell me what
you think or can you send it to your
friends and then you click it and it's
this really big black guy yeah his dick
is like down to his knee and he's
smiling at you did I ever tell you guys
my Tim wild story I tell you I don't
know okay so there's a guy that I knew
in San Diego used to improv with them
and he was one of those guys we've never
quite could get with chicks very easily
and so he devised a thing where he he
said you can buy a Tim Wow which is just
a date with him and he'd treat like a
ShamWow so he felt like a commercial
where it's like it's like you get a date
with me and you get it comes with an
appetizer and a dinner and whatever
right and then and so he he like trying
to get on The Today Show with it on a
bunch of stuff and so i i i i wrote like
a five paragraph thing about how i was
like i was an SDS used to din and like I
really was touched by his video and how
I just thought that he was really cool
and like I'm I'm into music and like I'm
working on my degree right now I'm
trying to get a degree in veterinary
medicine but like we'll see how no it's
a little stressful right now and then by
the end of the thing I was like anyway
there's a photo of me attached if you
want to talk like let me know and I just
got a picture with you know Craigslist
and it's just like a gut like this with
his heart
so then uh like three weeks later i was
down there and I saw the guy and I was
like yeah how's it going with the Tim
walking right and he's like he's like
yeah it's going pretty good I was like
yeah you probably get like I watched
answer sick [ __ ] he's like he's like
yeah man it's like somebody sent me a
picture of a [ __ ] dish like [ __ ]
did Mike nail into my hand so hard to
stop myself from laughs laughs - cuz you
laughs oh my god like that this video
now yeah I know it's been a long time so
though you can no thank you know the bit
nobody you gotta put it with an email
that's like so I found your old baby I
just wanted him to be there and he's
just saying like dude just [ __ ] all day
oh really yep just only women question
his sexuality because he was like you
know liked it we had a I had a strong
connection with this one person but it's
not my usual anyway she's trying to get
into vet school right now so I all right
here we go
headline into JK with that story
yeah officials have to airlift mountain
goats out of a state park because they
are addicted to human urine whoa Wow
mountain goat high off of it so they
have to like put them through [ __ ]
goat that rehab yeah they stopped
drinking human piss it's kind of funny
because they're airlifting them out and
have to blindfold them so they don't
know how to get home
so this sixth place in Olympic National
Park in Washington State
and how is it disruptive so they're just
drinking pee because it's like the
humans like humans that go and like they
hike and stuff like they sing the demons
cause I'm like give me your piss I can
tell you about full bladder just like a
goat just comes out yeah what's up that
piss look real good homie where you
going
a bunch of goats like where you going
it's scary every just stops you and
starts licking his lips like what I'm
picturing I'm picturing like hikers
[ __ ] taking a piss
and as soon as like the hiker starts
pissing these goats are like oh [ __ ] and
then they all just surround them like a
zombie and start [ __ ] drinking their
pee and they can't stop in the middle of
it and then they come out and they
[ __ ] bite their dick why do so yo
what the [ __ ] is he doing literally
trying to drink it he's juicing on piss
yeah is it like people piss and then
they come and drink their piss and in
their develops a taste for human waste
due to um Wow because they don't well
you know we drink their milk like Joe's
like go smoke so good you know maybe
they're just getting us bad but they're
not drinking human breast milk but milk
is food but but your aim comes from
human yeah yeah I miss goats come from
Olmo comes from goats
we're drinking their excrements and
they're drinking ours I'll never forget
the video I saw Bill Gates
he's part of the invention of some
device that takes like water like sewer
water and I'll never forget the video of
Bill Gates like just drinking [ __ ] but
he was drinking clear it was clear
yeah but he's like he's like the great
thing about this is that it's a hundred
percent human waste it was filtered and
then just like do you know that our tap
water is filtered [ __ ] what like we we
actually yeah and actually filter our
waste and then it goes back into order
David we talk about we do process we
already do that all baby that's why they
say yeah that's why they say don't put
pharmaceuticals and oils and fats and
stuff down the drain
because that goes right back into our
system what if I I guess shoot I shoot a
little bit of 409 in there
because my st. Panna smells that you
just need charcoal filters oh [ __ ]
you'll be fine we do have a Britta don't
worry yeah use the promo restaurant we
definitely drew tab
oh yeah we drink tab and it smells do
you ever notice that Oh young reason the
cups smell like [ __ ] dirty rats they
put so much ice in there because then
the ice makes it so you can't smell it
yeah really yeah I always ask for a
lemon it makes the salt go away yeah
dude it's gross private in New York York
City tap water is I heard that's better
the pizzas better because the water
something in the water dude we had a New
York cheesecake and that shows legit bro
it's like actually better than what I
cuz we thought it was all hype and then
we had a were like oh it's the water
no the bagels are the biggest difference
really give her a bag on New York it
will blow your mind what's the best
pizza place not from Starbucks
no pizza what is it Joe's pizza no
sweets I'm Street pizza really yeah the
Prince Street and I saw the freaking
line was like three million hours long
and I'm like no I'm good and I went
around the core wedding parties people
sure know everyone okay exactly remember
that it's the best pizza no but then is
I'm saying like it was okay because on
the next day Isaac and I had pizza again
at this other spot and I can't remember
the name of it but that Pizza murdered
know me knows me knows good Chicago
deep-dish
all of the New York Pizza for me you
like deep dish I don't like deep dish
here but in Chicago
oh it's even deeper in Chicago that
shit's like a real pie that shit's like
that's just like three inches rock oh my
god when you eat when you're drunk it
was so good a million cuz I remember
when Taco Bell is like what five-star
chef oh yeah
I had pinks like chili cheese hot dog
and it was like the greatest hot dog of
my life and then I went back when I was
sober I'm like wow I've never seen a
sober person that thinks before yeah
that would be crazy to see the club you
were just like standing straight
ordering just get the regular hotdogs
with the Mexican people with the bacon
wrapped around and that's the [ __ ]
yeah the outside of the club [ __ ] that
shit's bomb dude dude there was this
whole this hotdog place across the
street from me in Hollywood called
Scooby's and they would use a Hawaiians
Kings bread buns and they put like
pineapples on it was so fun we do that
at dog house yeah dude I've only gotten
sick like for poison food poisoning from
like corporate stores like the guys on
the street with the grills and [ __ ] they
always like cook the [ __ ] out of that
stuff yeah yeah I never got sick from
those LA dogs poisoning from airline
food and also KFC that's crazy
although one time I got like basically
dysentery from a taco stand but my
friend got [ __ ] up on the tacos street
tacos but the hotdogs never but I went
back because that place is so [ __ ]
yep go to talk about people here and
like we talked about restaurant French
people urine that'd be so funny this
like drinking piss is like Japanese
you're chasing down all the Japanese
tourists why cuz I know us why and I
couldn't get to it
so they're saying that it's because they
they're always searching for salt and
minerals in mountain environments to
survive off of and so that's why you're
in is oh is that where they eat Cam's
can yeah because of the iron may be
solid
they have like big blocks of salt that
they have for at the farms and [ __ ] for
the animals to live hot licks
yeah but they love so the salt and
mineral is in human urine and packs
sweat on clothing the pond dig in areas
on the ground where where hikers have
peed or where they water and stuff
so then now what they're doing is that
they're airlifting all these goats out
of that area they're saying that it's
approximately 625 to 675 mountain goats
oh my god and yeah they're doing one by
one I think it is I think it is one by
one
yeah like it's like just what if salt to
them is like creatine and they that's
how they stay so [ __ ] buff ball fast
go dude yeah get murdered by one of
those things dude they mountain climb
all day cute that they blindfold this is
a good cartoon go oh yeah cartoon muscle
go do you remember that movie operation
Dumbo was like maybe it's not relevant
it was a movie about where they're just
yeah I got a Vietnam I thought it was
called Operation jumbo and then I would
have [ __ ] it up but they were supposed
to airlift or like drop off an elephant
that was the plot device of the whole
but the whole movie is you see an
elephant parachuting down into the
ground
it's amazing what's the beginning middle
in it I have no I remember it was about
an elephant getting airdrop somewhere so
[ __ ] far and it did really well I
think kids yeah documentary you might
have been - oh it was with bad guys who
were trying to stop them from airlifting
the elephant or the [ __ ] hilarious
[Music]
[Music]